-John and I are about to face
off in a game of "Box of Lies."
Now, here's how it works.
Upstage are nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
and describe it
to your opponent.
They have to guess
whether you're lying
or telling the truth.
We're going to play
three rounds.
John, why don't you pick
the first box?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Far too far for me to reach.
I'm going to go for four.
Gonna go for four.
-I didn't hear one person
out there say four.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, doesn't seem that heavy,
but, then again,
you're John Cena.
-That's correct.
-Nothing is heavy to John Cena.
Okay.
♪♪♪♪
This is all part --
It's all part of the game
right now already.
He's deciding whether to tell
the truth or tell me a lie.
Okay.
-This object, Jimmy Fallon...
-Uh-huh.
-...is made of precious metal.
-Okay.
Precious metal.
-And gemstones.
Precious metal and gemstones.
-It's beautiful to look at.
-Okay.
-And if you were
to see it up close,
you wouldn't be able
to look away.
[ Light laughter ]
-It's something bejeweled.
-It might be.
[ Light laughter ]
Actually, it certainly is,
because I just --
because I just told you it was.
-That's right.
Yeah, you did, yeah.
-And I am holding,
from box number four,
cosmetic lipstick.
-Lipstick.
-Yeah.
-So what you're saying
is it's a bejeweled lipstick.
-Yes.
-Why didn't you just say that
in the first place?
That's ridiculous.
I mean, this is the --
this is the dumbest thing
that anyone's ever done
in the history of the game
"Box of Lies."
If that's really
a lipstick container,
that took 20 minutes for you to
describe a lipstick container.
-This is your game, bro.
-Precious metal --
-I was just trying --
-Precious metals and gems?
-Yes, yes!
-It's a lipstick container?
-It is a lipstick container.
-You are telling the truth!
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-But it says -- it says,
"Open and twist."
-Yeah.
-Now, that --
-You shanghaied me!
-Now, that would have --
that would have been something
to talk about.
Here we go.
Guys, what box?
What number?
[ Audience shouting ]
Three.
Give them what they want.
-Three.
Go for it.
-[ Groaning ]
-So, it's not heavy.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoop.
-I've seen you strain.
-[ Singing ]
-It's not -- It's not large.
It's not large.
You're trying to -- You're
trying to think up an untruth.
-It's not large.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
It's...
It's two little honeybees.
And they're -- they're, uh...
[ Laughter ]
They're playing --
What's that jump rope game
that you jump --
-Double Dutch.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-They're playing two double --
Two double bubbles.
-So you couldn't identify the
insects or the jump rope game.
-The jump rope game
double Dutch.
And, yeah.
And there's two fuzzy bumblebees
playing it.
And their friends that are
playing along with them are --
-You --
-Two --
-You are not good.
-They are two, um...
praying mantises.
-Oh, fantastic.
Fantastic, yes.
All right.
-Manti.
Praying manti.
-Okay, that -- You know what?
-The plural of "mantis."
-That swung me.
-There's no way
you're telling the truth.
You're lying.
♪♪♪♪
-Welcome to my --
[ Foghorn blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
What number do you want
from John Cena?
[ Audience shouting ]
-I have a one.
I have a whole section.
Sorry, six guy.
I have a whole section
saying, "One."
All right.
-Six guy.
-One.
Forever be known as six guy.
Okay.
-Sorry, six guy.
-All right.
-Whew.
All right.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Light laughter ]
Okay.
♪♪♪♪
-It's art.
-Okay.
It's art.
-I find it beautiful.
-Okay.
-I think it
combines industrialism
with the early stages
of television.
[ Light laughter ]
-Industrialism, okay.
-I hold in my hands
a red and black
double pinstripe model
of a 1970 Chevy Chevelle SS.
And in the driver's seat
is the Fonz.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
From the looks of it,
it looks like a four-speed car.
It does look like it has
a 12-bolt rear end.
It appears to be a big block.
It is a Super Sport model.
-I know you --
-The Fonz is wearing his classic
black leather jacket.
-Uh-huh, uh-huh.
-He's a smaller figurine
in the passenger seat,
but it also looks like
he's wearing blue jeans,
if he has any pants on at all.
[ Light laughter ]
-So you're telling me -- you're
telling me that there's a --
there's a pantless Fonz
driving...
a 1970, like -- some type
of a souped-up muscle car.
-No, it's not --
Here's the thing.
It's not souped-up.
It is absolutely factory stock.
-Oh, keep talking, buddy.
Keep talking, 'cause guess what.
I know you, buddy.
I know you, Johnathan Cena.
Johnathan Cena, I know you.
And I know that you like cars.
So, I think
that you made this up.
This is a lie.
Is that right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
I love you, man.
I know you, dude.
I know you love cars.
[ Cheers and applause ]
John Cena, everybody!
Oh, my goodness.
His new children's book
"Elbow Grease" is out now.